The example we just saw using Csmith to test C compilers represented several years of work
by my group--it's really sort of a large effort for us.
What I want to show now is a different example of random testing.
We're going to test the tiny UNIX utility function using the very tiny random tester.
And so if you remember a couple of units ago we talked about the UNIX read system call,
so let's look at the read system call works.
Before I get going into this example, I should apologize a bit for dropping in to see here.
I try to work this example into Python and it really just didn't come out right--
there just didn't feel right and it sort of inherently a C example.
So it's not going to matter if you don't know C or shouldn't like C--I'll go through the code.
Really it would be rather simple.
The UNIX read system call as called from the C program tips the arguments.
It takes fd which is a file descriptor, it takes a buf which is a 0.02, a block of memory
into which data going to be read, and it takes a number of bytes to read from the file
represented by the file descriptor into the memory blocked pointed to by buf.
And now usually what the read system call does is it reads the number of bytes that you expected
into the memory block that you provided and all was good.
The return value of read is going to be the number of bytes read,
so that's what usually happens, but there a couple of other things that can happen.
A second possibility is the read system call then returns 0,
indicating that you've reached the end of the file.
Another thing that can happen is it can return -1 if it failed.
But the fourth possibility and this is the one that sort of pernicious and its one that a lot of programmers
get wrong is that read can return the number of bytes less than the number you asked for
and this isn't a failure--this just doesn't represent any sort of out of memory condition
or end of file or anything like that--it just means we need to try again.
And so the little UNIX utility function that I'm going to test here is a different version of read.
It's a version of read called read all that acts just like read except that it' not going to have
this property of returning partial reads ever.
So what read always going to do is in the case of a partial read is going to just issue another read call
that picks up where the first call left off and it's going to repeatedly do that until the read is
complete or until some sort of an error or end of file condition occurs.
So if anything bad happens, it will just return a -1 value
which is the sort of standard UNIX error value.
If the read calls a succeeding but returning a partial results, we're just going to keep issuing
read calls until we're finished, and so let's look at the code that does this.